Feeling which are socially isolated,
it's related to being physically
isolated from other people,
but it's not the same thing.
One can be lonely in a marriage,
lonely in a family,
they can be lonely in a crowd.
So we found it isn't the number of
contacts or the frequency of interaction
with other people.
It's the quality of those interactions.
Freshmen who have gone to college find
themselves among many,
many other people,
lots of social activities.
They go to mixers and they look out.
Everyone else is talking with other
people and they're sitting there all
alone in their head and so that actually
can make their feeling of isolation
greater for that moment.
So being around other people,
that's not what makes people less
lonely.
It's feeling connected.
Tell other people that makes them feel
less lonely.
Traditionally,
loneliness and depression,
loneliness and anxiety with treated as
very similar constructs.
So much so that one of the common
measures of depression that used in
epidemiology has.
As one of the questions,
do you feel lonely?
Uh,
our own researcher,
Mr Trump,
others have looked at whether loneliness
and depression to the same thing.
And we find them to be separate
contracts,
they're separate.
Mental states are longitudinal research
and our experimental research has shown
that loneliness leads to increased
depressive symptomatology.
So if no matter how depressed you are
today,
if you're feeling lonely today,
you will be more depressed a year from
now,
above and beyond what your level of
depression today would predict because
of the loneliness.
We also find that depression leads you
to withdrawal,
so at difference in depression and
loneliness,
loneliness makes you want to reach out
and contact other people,
be a part of that group,
be a part of that relationship.
Depression is associated with depressed
an effect,
but also with lethargy,
kind of this withdrawal from others,
and indeed with depression,
we find over time people do withdraw
from others and that withdrawal and the
increased stress associated with that
leads them to field lonelier.
So you have this pernicious feedback
loop below maynard.
They are,
the more depressed they become,
the more depressed they are,
the more they withdraw and the lonelier
they become.
If you look at those two effects of the
effect of loneliness and depression is
stronger than the effect of depression
on loaning us.
People can be depressed for other
reasons and feeling lonely,
but many people who go in to seek
treatment for depression at the root of
the problem is their feeling of
disconnection and isolation and unless
that's treated,
the depression or any attempt to fix
that is really just kind of a transient
bandaid.
It's not getting at the root problem.
The measurements of loneliness is
somewhat not obvious.
Bob People know that they feel isolated,
they feel disconnected.
They don't have others on whom they can
rely or talk,
but it's mostly they don't have a
confidant.
They don't have anyone who affirms who
they are.
That's part of it.
Now,
if you ask people,
do they feel lonely?
There tends to be this stigma associated
with loneliness.
I think our research has suggested it's
an inappropriate stigma,
but there's nevertheless the stigma
associated with the loneliness,
so people underreport.
If you ask them,
do you feel lonely?
They under report,
but if you ask them,
are there others,
son whom they can rely to,
whom they can relate to and whom they
can confide a.
that's when you start to see people
admitting this feeling of isolation.
There's also this sense in which they
don't have a collective identity,
so immediately after nine slash 11 when
we all survived that tragedy,
it made being an American salient.
That's a social identity,
but if you notice in this country,
journalists were writing about the
harmony,
the goodwill that existed in America.
That was a step up of what had been felt
weak before nine slash 11.
That's part of being connected and so
that alone,
the individual is also absent that
social identity,
and it may be in the form of feeling
like you're an American after a tragedy
or it might be a Chicago cubs are New
York Yankees Fan.
These kinds of identities are part of
how we are connected to other other
individuals and other groups and loamy
individuals tend to lock those as well.
There are several secrets to overcoming
or avoiding moments I.
I like to use the analog of of hunger.
A loneliness has evolved because it has
very adaptive purpose.
We are fundamentally social species,
but we need some signal when that
important need isn't being met.
Very much like hunger.
We need a reasonable level of blood
sugar or else we don't have the
metabolic resources,
the energy to pursue foraging and other
activities.
Uh,
when we start to have lower blood sugar
levels,
we become hungry,
uh,
and that's a signal that we should find
food and eat and refuel.
If we ignore that hunger signal.
If we think that somehow that
stigmatizing,
and so we simply persisted not pursuing
any food.
And ignoring that signal,
we can become so depleted of energy that
we're no longer able to seek that food
so it can become chronic and deadly.
Loneliness is very much like that man.
Instead of sustaining us with calories,
it seemed sustains us with connections
in evolutionary times.
We were not able to fend off large wild
beasts very well as individuals with the
stick.
Nor are we able to take care of our
offspring who had the longest period of
abject dependency of any species.
If we were simply solitary animals,
we are able to achieve a reproduction
survival and our offspring survive long
enough so that they to reproduce a
because we acted as a group as a
collective.
So find yourself ostracized or separated
from that group is a threatening
dangerous circumstance.
Recognizing that you also can understand
how the feeling of loneliness,
the pain of loneliness,
the threat that's associated with
loneliness is a signal very much like
hunger,
but it's there to cue the need to
reconnect,
to protect that part of our,
our existence.
Uh,
and if we respond to it,
is that cute?
Then it can be very healthy.
If you don't respond to that queue,
then you can fall into the grips of
chronic loneliness.
And that has been,
as I suggested,
very deleterious mental psychological
effects,
but also physiological effects.